foreign
hey Kristen what's up
hey Dr John how are you fantastic how
are you
good thanks for taking my calls of
course a celebrity in our home and there
may be a little jealousy Brewing that
I'm getting to talk to you today so
thank you well I am assuredly not a
celebrity in my own home so I'm glad I'm
famous in somebody's house that makes me
feel better thank you hey so what's up
I've got there's a lot to this so I'm
just going to jump right into it
Cannonball let's do it
I have made an appropriate boundary with
my family so I I want to give you just a
little preface to this story of course
at eight at eight years old I was the
victim of a murder suicide and lost both
of my parents
I was subsequently raised by my maternal
aunt and her husband
so fast forward 35 years later I have
been married I have a fantastic husband
who's the greatest in the world and I
have three adult children that are great
also
um we have our two our two oldest
children are out of the house and we
have a 19 year old daughter who has
special needs she is diagnosed with
autism anxiety and bipolar disorder so
she's our sidekick she goes everywhere
with us she functions at about a 14 year
old level
so we went home this weekend to see
family and stayed at my I stayed at my
parents house and I'm going to refer to
my aunt and uncle as my parents because
that's what I was conditioned to do as a
young child so we stayed at my parents
house
um also my dad's sister and her husband
came into town
uncle is a kisser he always has been
nope nope a kisser and a hugger nope so
it's always been super weird to me even
as a as a young kid I dreaded it but it
was like hey that's him he's weird what
are you gonna do about it that's assault
no
so I don't necessarily think of him as a
pervert doesn't matter doesn't matter
it's weird right
listen listen listen it's not weird
if somebody
touches you puts their mouth on you
and we use the word kissing and it has a
different connotation and sometimes it
can be innocent if an adult puts their
mouth on a child or on somebody else who
doesn't want their mouth on their body
that is assault
period it's not well he's just weird
it is a violation of bodily autonomy
can't do it that's exactly where I'm
going so we
my my 19 year old daughter expressed
after after uncle had kissed her at
lunch Mommy I don't like that and I'm
like oh me either I've been dealing with
it for 35 years it's gross Mom you go to
war mom go to war for your special needs
daughter
that's what happened good so I tell my
mom that night you know this
although it's so weird whatever and and
she kind of blew me off and
you know I just I said she doesn't like
it well you know what happened to the
days when kids were disrespectful of
their elders and they just did what they
did you know God dude you are freaking
me out man that's abuse that's abuse
it's abuse no no no she just told me my
kids could stand to be a little more
respectful that my kids don't spend
enough time with her they don't hug her
and unfortunately my children are overly
close to anybody in our family because
my husband served in the military we
weren't home air quote home for my kids
to be close to any one relative and so
it's just never been a thing that I've
been like oh you've got to go hugging
you've got to go do this I just didn't
do that because I knew my kids weren't
close Christian
you are right
okay
number one hold on listen number one
I'm on my end and I get to be this way
because I'm not in your shoes I'm
disgusted that your mom talked to you
like that
it made this a matter of integrity and
honor and back in the old days when kids
would just let adults do whatever they
wanted
that like makes me sick to my stomach
because I got a seven-year-old little
girl
and I'll be damned if somebody's gonna
do that to my daughter holy smokes
yeah now hold on hold on hold on
number two
what this Uncle is doing is wrong and
his defense maybe nobody's ever told him
your special needs daughter reached out
to Mom
and in all due respect you put her in a
situation
with somebody who has repeatedly made
you feel uncomfortable your entire life
and violated you your whole life
and she looked at you and said mom
please I don't like this
that's your job right now
right and if she was a 19 year old and
she called my show and she didn't
um was didn't have the cognitive
capacity of a 14 year old and wasn't
struggling with a bunch of cognitive
challenges I would tell her don't ever
go again and if your parents throw a fit
then walk away from your parents because
they're putting you in a crazy situation
she doesn't have that kind of autonomy
she's with she stuck with you guys so
it's your job to say no
and you can on her behalf tell your uh
your uncle
she doesn't like to be hugged or kissed
so please don't do that
okay and then if you violate that he
through his behavior is choosing for you
all to not come around
period okay you all aren't leaving y'all
aren't abandoning the family y'all
aren't after all we did for you no
pervert Uncle over here
is chosen for us to leave because he
can't keep his mouth off my 19 year old
daughter's body
right period
and I would go to Dairy Queen with my
family there in Texas or actually I
wouldn't go to Dairy Queen I would go to
some awesome Mexican restaurant because
you'll have the best food on the planet
in San Antonio
I would eat myself into a diabetic coma
and I'd with a smile on my face because
I'm not gonna be around that crap I'd
smile on the way home
so bodily autonomy when my husband
dropped that word on her very
respectfully also good for your husband
not a boy look at look at Texans coming
around it's awesome yeah well he was
like Dr John would tell me to say that
so it was like a complete shift in her
demeanor and she asked us to leave good
she she was that upset and told us that
she told me that I let an 85 year old
man ruin our relationship she didn't
tell us no have a safe trip home nothing
she decided she decided that an 85 year
old man had more of a right to y'all's
body than you all do
that's what she decided and by the way
she's the adult she's the parent now I
know you're an adult and there's a
mutual respect and all that kind of
thing
she's your mom
and if she's gonna let an 85 year old
man who can't keep his mouth off people
come between y'all and she's immature
and it breaks my heart for you because
you don't need to lose another mom but
she walked away
and that's my that's my other thing is
that I for 35 years have have long to
have this mother figure I know the
accepting of me and what and and so
there's nothing to do with you I know
I've just done everything to try to
appease her and make her happy but
nothing I do ever does and so I guess
that's where I'm at it's not about you I
hate this I hate it I hate it I hate it
and the way she spoke to my husband she
severed the boundaries not you
okay
what you have to do is deal with the
heartache and the grief that your mom
did that
not yeah
somebody I feel like you know I feel
like I'm walking on eggshells with my
sisters now and I feel like you know I
because she's made me feel that way but
in reality what I want to do is protect
my kids at all costs and protect you
protect your own dignity you've put up
with the stuff your whole life
I have it's time it's time for you to
stop Reaching For This Woman's approval
it's you're never gonna get it
she'll continue that so hard for me to
grasp I because again 35 years I've I've
sought her approval and I've never once
gotten it no because because you're
because you're still a little girl
wondering why your mom left
you're still a little girl wondering
this woman came in and said I'll let you
and I'll take I'll take over from here
and what a gracious beautiful gift your
your aunt who you call Mom gave you
and then she there were lots of strings
attached she weaponized that that's
right she weaponized it so it's both and
she gave you a roof and she gave you
food and that came with a lot of strings
I did and now you're an adult and you
see it and sometimes when you're an
adult with integrity and you're an adult
who
um
uh has learned from the dumb things
you've done in your childhood and you
look back
it's disgusting
to see other adults who haven't yes
right it's maddening right it almost
makes you feel insane like am I the
crazy one but here's here's how I found
in my life how I cut through some of
what you're dealing with with your
sisters
and it is to stop using what I call the
soft Landing words
like
just tight hugs or ugh kisses that's a
soft way of saying he keeps putting his
hands all over my body
he keeps putting his mouth on my
daughter's body
and when you use very descriptive
language of what's Happening
he keeps rubbing his forearm on my
breast and I don't like it huh he keeps
whatever the he keeps putting his hands
really low on my back to where his
fingers touch the top of my butt and I
hate it right whatever the language is
be very specific and everybody gets it
you can't deny it at that point and they
can call you dramatic
oh my gosh it's not putting your mouth
it's just kissing ugh and it's just
gross whatever it's just fun it's just
Uncle Dan cool y'all knock your lights
out put your daughters in that situation
moms of the year
I just don't want to teach my daughter
that to start you know suffer through
verse than
than you know I don't I don't know the
greatest gift a mom can give her
daughter a is to believe her and B is to
say I hear you and I'm taking you out of
Harm's Way
okay
and so at this point
am I burning a bridge do I sever ties I
I don't feel like I owe anyone an
apology I feel super guilty listen
you've heard this show enough choose
guilt over resentment every time yes I
know my husband already told me you were
going to say that you're gonna feel
guilty you're gonna feel guilty you're
gonna feel guilty it's better than
hating your mom
yeah so choose guilt
guilt that you feel bad about all those
things that's normal that's fine my
daughter just kept telling me I'm so
sorry Mom if I hadn't said anything we
wouldn't be doing this I said absolutely
not this is not your fault this is
bigger than you I want you to do
something to this evening
um and if she can hear it and again
she's got a lot going on so this is easy
for me to say on this side of it and
actually I'm saying this for not only
for you but for every mom with a
daughter in a similar situation by the
way this is a super common situation
and most of the time the men involved I
don't think are bad guys
right I don't think they're all perverts
and they're all just trying to get some
from a young girl I don't think so I
think they are trying to forge
connections
and the only way they know how is
through hugs and kisses
yeah okay that's just I think that's the
that's the Playbook and they didn't have
a language for assault they didn't have
a language for it
intimate and I reserve that for my
husband there you go well I would hope
so I would hope it's not for your uncle
right no God no but listen here's what I
want you to do with your daughter so
weird I want you to
sit down with your daughter so that
y'all are eye level
even if she sits down and you get on
both knees in front of her
and I want you to put both hands on both
sides of her face
and I want you to tell her I am so proud
of you
my heart's about to burst
because when I was a little girl
Uncle so and so did that to me all the
time and I hated it and I hated it and I
hated it
and either I never said anything
because I wasn't allowed or I said
something a lot and my mommy didn't
protect me
I'm gonna protect you
I know I want you to make her feel not
just through words but I want her to
experience you saying I'm so proud of
you
okay I can do that I'll do it
I know I want her to have a voice you've
taught her you've taught her that you've
taught her that for 19 years
yes and what this also means let's just
cut to like be super clear this also
means you and your husband and your
other kids y'all probably gonna have to
have a different Thanksgiving Christmas
this year
that's okay that's okay plan it be
intentional about it we're all going to
North Carolina for whatever we're all
going to Dallas and we're don't go to
Dallas we're all going to Houston for
whatever like whatever but okay we're
going we're doing our own thing this
year
okay and at some point maybe maybe Mom
can have a rational conversation
and she'll say what happened what did we
do to make you and you can say with all
love in your heart and respect and
kindness
Uncle so and so made me feel
uncomfortable and he kissed me and he
touched me whatever
for 40 years
then he did it to my daughter
come to find out he did it to one of my
other daughters too
and as long as he comes to these things
me and my family as for our house we're
opting out and so at the end of the day
Mom you get to choose and that's okay
and I know you've got a lot going on
but Mom you get to pick
and then you just smile because she's a
grown-up it's about time she stopped one
down positioning everybody and pulling
the whole boat around underneath the
water
right I mean we very much were raised to
hide your crazy and just go on just you
know we were supposed to be very stoic
and not tell anybody anything those days
are over good for you Kristen good for
you
I'll hide my crazy that's fine
it comes to people abusing my daughter
violating her bodily autonomy
nope
nope by the way that goes for my son too
that goes for my wife too that goes for
me too
those days where we all just be quiet
and let Uncle so and so be weird all
Uncle so and so that's over
and let it be over in your house too
thanks for the call Kristen you are
awesome